yeah this looks just like the globe whoa
no it's a spread gun now is that how it
always was no definitely not
[Applause]
don't leave me finally
all right guys what's up welcome back to
potato mode the show where we take the
best looking games out there turn the
graphics in the bush my name is Joey I'm
joined here by Jean Luc hello and today
we are playing some Borderlands 2 a very
it was a much requested game not by a
lot of people but for those dedicated
few especially this guy Calvin Knight
because I think commented on every
single episode so far with the
suggestion so thank you so much for that
we're finally getting around to it and
by the way if you guys liked the show
you know just make why not click this
little link up in the corner you know
we've got a lot of more episodes for you
maybe even featuring a game that you're
probably typing into the the chat box
right now to comment but for now we have
Borderlands 2 and this game is gonna be
interesting for us for a good number of
reasons John Luke yeah it's a very
pretty game he's got that nice
cel-shaded look to it the dark outlines
and like the very like chunky look oh my
god we're already getting into it right
yeah and remember when minecraft was a
thing should we just head somewhere
let's head somewhere there's a lot of
different vistas that we can visit in
the game I think right all of them are
pretty pretty mountainous like barren
but still still very beautiful so what I
want to do first is I kind of want to
take the the look of the game and I want
to I want to change it a little bit we
all know that Borderlands is iconic for
like its cartoony style with like the
black fat outlines and like the cell
shade look so I was thinking what if we
just get rid of that hey man all right
so what we have here are two windows and
on the left here we have the config
files for the game under the willow file
slash config folder and over here I have
a couple of copies
of this the the willow engine config
file and that's the one that you can use
to change all the different settings
like basically any any graphical setting
that you could think of you can change
it in there so what I did was I went
into and I changed one line and I got
rid of the words willow in the front of
engine in front of scene and so that
theoretically should a get rid of our
black borders hopefully so I'm gonna
bring this in and we'll see what happens
Oh a whoo that's really weird actually
it is is kind of off-putting it not only
got rid of the black outlines but also
like the cell shading look I think we're
like it I don't think it flattens like
all the light I don't know it's weird
flame rock refuge I suppose this place
is gonna look nice oh yeah strange I
think look at these people like the
lighting completely changes when you or
maybe just the illusion of the lighting
changes when you take away those black
borders like it still looks like
Borderlands but but there's something
off there's something severely wrong
with the game all right do we want to
try taking a step further yeah I think
we can actually make it look like
there's something severely wrong with
the game do let's do it okay so I have a
setting right here which is just labeled
you know potato but we're gonna take
that same line that we edited earlier
and we're gonna copy it into the potato
on just so that we can get that nice of
borderless lands look oh boy
[Laughter]
something else our work tube no so I
think the the decision to remove the
black borders was probably a good one I
think we it really retains that potato
equality to it except for that sign that
is perfectly fine I'm not sure how that
one skipped skipped by so in the config
file that I edited there's a actually a
lot of little details and little like
there are a lot of little details a lot
of little numbers that I oh my god what
are you doing I messed that pulled on
the the change in there so I can't
really detail them all but I will put a
couple of links in the description so
you can copy that and then if you want
you can edit this into your game yeah
and go nuts but the the Minecraft hit on
what does that even look like that's the
Jacqueline where's the Mike it looks the
same the Minecraft wants the same you
can't potato five Mike that's the best
look or can you Minecraft potato mode
coming soon I will neither confirm or
deny that well saying this is the best
looking one here it's untouched can you
give us a quest ma'am
oh we could do some slot machine of old
past aha
well I win are we gonna get I'm actually
these are iridium machines so much this
is my radio oh I got money I think we
should quit while we're ahead
all right let's try and like kill some
dudes oh wait I see yeah the gun looks
like it's just missing all the major
like little little textures I kind of
give you that Borderlands look yeah I
got this graveyard is looking rough a
lot more like mood lighting to it the
original version do you have anything
that explodes by any chance aside from
the aside from the fireball oh I
actually hurt myself it's a good
old-fashioned potato fication of
explosions where they're all just
squares enchanted remember we need to be
fair I don't think anything's supposed
to look like what it does right now
that's very true yeah this looks just
like the globe whoa no it's a spread gun
now is that how it always was no
definitely not
let's pick another area at random okay
15 where where 15 is well we'll go there
oh oh well we see the moon well kind of
I mean this is
called the wasteland right yeah yeah if
you're looking for something desolate
even more desolate than what Borderlands
already offers Brown Whaley edit the
config file because there is there's a
lot going on here this was cool a little
City area reflective glass wonder if
that'll show up at all which will most
likely be not reflective anymore kind of
its reflecting something I'm not sure if
it's light or what those were bushes
right yes I believe so
or like Sims icons maybe oh god that's
that's some really really red blood
think that's how that was in the
original game he's just pay off cuz all
his blood left him sometimes I wonder if
these graphics will over catch on you
know like a potato mode game yeah
because there are games that have you
know like Borderlands like a lot of
other games just very simple graphics
and as far as like cell shading goes and
now I think we're we're part of a
parvenu oh my gosh this was always one
of my favorite areas this is this log
this area looks really cool like it's
still it's still green still hurts me
but doesn't have that same mm we've done
this as so many games by now but there
are some that still have like that kind
of almost like a charm to it that you
can still see like what they were going
for right there's a secret Easter egg
here
yeah there's a Minecraft Easter egg we
get the Minecraft head yep here it is oh
my god things are still intact Wow
yeah you know we've done something bad
when the minecraft textures look better
than the rest of the cake definitely
forever destroy all these blocks all
right that's minecraft Joey for you you
know I know minecraft I think we gotta
go back to a sanctuary
alright but before we do I want to break
the game a little bit so I'm just gonna
bring the last one in here and yeah it's
gonna be broken
hopefully Wow Joey what did you do
the thing is I don't remember and I
tried fixing his eye eye it was actually
a lot worse so I changed a lot of
different values and I couldn't quite
get the one that brought the text or
brought the model of the character back
and I couldn't figure it out
so this is what we're dealing with right
here oh no I can't even maybe we should
just that you get fast travel just back
to sanctuary that might be safer okay we
know we're indoors okay yeah inside the
station where are we cool hi moxie
Oh inside the bar yeah I'm talking to
right now
I'm giving her a tip hi chef where are
you Joey this is a nightmare used to the
right of this noise further up further
forward yeah odd memories past this oh
we can we can switch back to like the
the previous version if you want to
actually see him in order to end the
show no it's okay you sure I'm gonna
attempt to give him a high five I'm
failing horror I think you think you may
move forward a little bit alright let's
go back to them okay that's potato
everybody Congrats we did it alright
let's just go back to the menu so we can
actually see something
Hillier okay well thank you guys so much
for watching if you'd like to see more
potato mode we have a playlist for you
put up right again right in the corner
here and if you liked this show make
sure to check out our one of our other
shows grave hoppers which is on
Thursdays 2 p.m. every Thursday I said
Thursday twice didn't I oh yeah you can
check that out right here now I have a
trailer let's play it welcome to grave
hoppers the show where we put permadeath
into every game you die in a game you
move on to the next oh my god dude you
had no help
watch us struggle to survive every
Thursday we'll see you then what hit me
[Music]
no I like how you put up your hands as
if like we were watching it as well
we're watching it hey play that trailer
today way in the back thanks guys so
much for watching again if you have a
game that you want to see potato fight
like this leave in the comments below
and we'll someday get to it like we did
with Borderlands 2 so we will see you
all next Friday you sure you're not on
some deserted island you know it's hard
to say anymore I have a thing where
every time I shoot my reloads faster
yeah so I reload faster and shoot faster
and my jucy goes down but my damage that
goes up but my shields come back
whenever I kill a man point is I can't
die and I also can't hit B but at
point-blank range